welcome to the man of Recaps this is
your complete Marvel recap for the
Marvels we begin with the first Captain
Marvel we meet an apparently human woman
who's an elite warrior in the alien Cree
Empire she has no memory of her past
life so she thinks her name is beers the
cre are at war with the evil
shape-shifting Scrolls and during a
battle viers crash lands on Earth back
in the 90s she teams up with Shield
agent young Nick Fury and fills him in
about the scroll threat but soon veers
uncovers the mysteries of her past she
is a human Carol Danvers she was a
fighter pilot a new super engine built
with the Tess the space Stone but the
Creed tried to steal it so Carol crashed
the engine exploded and blasted her with
a super space Powers so Carol realizes
the cre have been lying to her all along
and they meet with the scr leader Talos
who's like yeah no they're the bad guys
we're the good guys so Carol daners
reclaims her identity changes her
uniform from the cre colors to the good
old US Air Force Carol teams up with her
old pilot best friend Maria Rambo who's
got a young daughter Monica they also
recruit the cat goose who is an alien
flurin waa watch out for that and when
he scratches Nick Fury's eye yep that's
how he lost it as they fight to stop the
cre Invasion soon Carol realizes the
chip they put on her to help control her
powers was suppressing her powers she
rips it off and oh she's glowing goes
full Super Saiyan Captain Marvel
Unleashed she flies around in space
shooting energy beams takes out the
whole cre Fleet single-handedly but
Carol can't stick around on Earth she's
got to fly off and keep fighting the cre
but she gives Nick Fury her beeper
number like hit me up if there's a real
emergency that emergency happened in
Avengers Infinity War when Thanos
snapped away half the population Nick
Fury's last move was to send that text
so in Avengers endgame Captain Marvel
showed up and helped kick thanos's butt
let's do a quick recap on secret
invasion in case any of it comes up Nick
Fury became good friends with the scroll
leader Talos but a bad scroll gravic
takes over and he wants to conquer Earth
and DOW he kills Taos gravic got the DNA
of a bunch of super people wants to put
it all in himself to be the Super scroll
but Taos had a daughter Gia and she
blasts herself with the super DNA too so
they have a super scroll fight the
strongest of her powers is Captain
Marvel so blam coming hameha defeats
King Piccolo now it's time for Wanda
Vision long story short Wanda maximoff
the Scarlet Witch lost control of her
powers and turned this entire small town
into a sitcom where she and vision could
live happily ever after so we follow
agent Monica Rambo yes Maria's daughter
from Captain Marvel she travels into the
hex to find out what's going on the
Wanda soon spots the impostor and kicks
her back out but Monica's not quitting
she's going in again which the science
people warn her could be real dangerous
indeed she makes it through but it did
something weird to her now she's got
some superpowers at the end she's
approached by scroll who invite her to
space for a secret mission they're
working with Nick Fury to build a space
station called saber and now it's time
for Ms Marvel Kamala Khan is a normal
teenage girl who is a Captain Marvel
Super Fan she's going to spice up her
cosplay with her Grandma's old bangal
but when she puts it on while what's
this it unlocks her super powers turns
out her grandma was a Jin an
interdimensional superperson her science
friend tells her that her genes have a
mutation yeah the first M bomb in the
MCU eventually the X-Men are coming but
for now Kamala protects Jersey City as
the minor superhero NightLight and she
Saves the World from her evil gin Auntie
then her mom SWS her a better super suit
and she learns how to master her powers
so she takes a new name from her Idol
Captain Marvel and becomes Miz Marvel
and in fact they do have a strange
connection because at the end she's
teleported away she swapped places with
Captain Marvel so Carol daners finds
herself in a teenager's bedroom in New
Jersey and the Marvel's will pick up
there if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and
movies